mardi peu après 17h30 les services de
gendarmerie de basse-pointe ont été
avisés de ce qu'ils avaient une grille
ce qui était en train de se produire sur
la place centrale du bourg donc de
passer de basse-pointe parvenu sur place
ils ne peuvent que constater que l'un
des protagonistes de cette rixe gît au
sol et malgré l'intervention rapide des
sapeurs pompiers puis ensuite du samu
l'intéressé ne se relèvera pas et sera
déclarée a été cédé aux environs de
18h15 rapidement la clameur publique
signale que ce sont deux individus qui
sont les auteurs des coups portés sur la
victime ces deux individus sont
rapidement donc identifier et
interpeller puisque l'un à quai sur
place et l'autre s'est rendu
immédiatement à la brigade de
gendarmerie de basse pointe
une des deux personnes qui ont été mises
en garde à vue fêter ce jour là son
anniversaire et qu'à cette occasion la
haye s'est fortement alcoolisé en
compagnie de plusieurs personnes qui se
sont rendues donc dans le bourg de
basse-pointe a carrément donné pour une
raison qui reste à déterminer
il a eu une altercation avec la future
victime et que celle ci semble bien
avoir porté plusieurs coups à son
endroit
au bout d'un moment un troisième
individu qui n'était pas présent au
moment du commencement donc de cette de
cette rixe est intervenu à lui également
eu une altercation avec la future
victime
il ya eu un échange manifestement de
coûts et au cours de cet échange
cette personne qui est donc ensuite été
placé en garde à vue semble avoir bien
sorti un couteau et avoir porté
plusieurs coups de couteau sur cette
victime les deux personnes placées en
garde à vue ont été déférés cet après
midi devant un magistrat instructeur
pour l'un il a été requis une mise en
examen du chef d'homicide volontaire
ainsi que son placement en détention
provisoire
quant au second celui qui a porté des
coups de béquille lui reprocher quant à
lui défait 2
de violences volontaires avec arme et il
a été revu requis à son endroit
placement sous contrôle judiciaire